we have some states who've made sudden
changes to their election systems
at the last minute and that is never a
good idea
isn't perhaps the biggest threat to your
democracy
the failure by the president to commit
to accepting the election result if he
loses
you know that's a stupid question really
a deeply divided america is heading for
its election with the polls showing many
people
afraid of violence after the vote my
guest this week from washington
is ken cuccinelli he's the acting number
two at the department of homeland
security
which caused uproar after reports of his
agents used excessive force
during recent protests in portland
oregon can his department keep the peace
in this critical period
[Music]
ken cuccinelli welcome to conflict zone
three weeks to polling day
in the us can americans have faith in
their electoral system
yeah absolutely this is the most
well-protected election we've ever had
and
at the federal level the federal
government has different
responsibilities in the states
we focus on cyber protection and dealing
with
nation states and people attacking the
whole system
we've got better surveillance than we've
ever had before
on the system and unlike four years ago
we have great
communication with all 50 states and the
district of columbia
about what we're seeing in the threats
that exist
that didn't happen four years ago so all
the scarce stories
we have all of our states participating
in our surveillance effort unlike only
about a third of them four years ago
so all the scare stories about massive
vote by mail fraud are simply untrue is
that right
now let me be careful i said the federal
government
focuses on the cyber threats what you're
describing the kind of
mail-in voter fraud those sorts of
things that i'll call
more traditional voter fraud are still
possibilities
and the states are responsible for
policing that the federal government
does not participate in that
except to provide them intelligence that
we discover on the subject
as part of our work but that is a state
responsibility and
every single state system is different
from
every other state's system so fraud
takes place
in one location at a time one state at a
time
and obviously we do everything we can to
support our state partners
in policing that well the fbi said that
last month the agency has not seen
evidence
of any coordinated national fraud effort
whether it's by mail or otherwise you
see any reason to doubt what the fbi has
told you
certainly not at a national level of
course a month ago voting hadn't started
voting has now started and you know we
we all see news stories about one thing
happening here or there in different
parts of the country
and you know we're paid to be worried
about that but so far
nothing a large scale that we have
detected
so what is it that president trump knows
that you don't when he says repeatedly
this is going to be the greatest
election disaster in history
the most corrupt election in the history
of our country the greatest fraud in the
history of elections
where did all these predictions of a
massively rigged election come from or
did he just make them up
i think he's concerned about
particularly states that
automatically mail out ballots to every
registered voter
and the concern that those could be
collected up and sent back in by people
to whom they were not mailed to they
weren't intended to go to
and we have some states who've made
sudden changes to their election systems
at the last minute and that is never a
good idea
i don't care what party you are or or
anything to be
essentially trying out a new system
including your security
in a presidential election year the
biggest turnout year of them all
that's the concern but what you're
telling me is very different from his
predictions the most corrupt election in
the history of our country this is what
he's forecasting
very different from what he has a
question yeah it's very different from
what you're saying
well i'm identifying them just wondering
if you're on the same page
and they're in their entire and their
entire states that uh that are operating
as i just described
your threat assessment talks about the
russians trying to sow distrust in
america's democracy
they don't really need to do they
because mr trump has done it for them
how could the russians possibly so more
mistrust in the democratic process than
he has
by predicting the greatest election
disaster in history
well hillary clinton was you has used
similar language in describing
uh her well her advice to her follow-on
campaigner joe biden and
in terms of after the election and so
forth candidates operate differently
than everybody else
and they have a role to play in the
process and people will judge
their votes based in part on the sorts
of things the candidates say
for russia to use your example they have
no such role
and they have no such right to
participate
unlike the candidates themselves so it's
a very very different situation
but the fact is that on the back of all
this incendiary rhetoric america is
arming itself to the teeth in advance of
this election isn't it
fbi says firearm sales hit a monthly
record of
3.9 million in june how concerned are
you about that people are buying guns
people in your country who've never
bought guns before
in advance of this election yeah i think
that's more tied to the civil unrest it
has nothing to do with the election
we've seen that spike
uh since the civil unrest began in the
spring
in may and i will tell you that in my
state of virginia
where i used to be the attorney general
i've heard from friends who
used to be supporters of gun control and
suppressing gun sales that they're
buying those guns and they're changing
their perspectives so
the civil unrest is really what's
driving the desire
for self-protection particularly when
you see the attacks on law enforcement
in this country that have taken place on
such a wide scale
and the fact that in some places and
i'll use again my home state
richmond the capital city of virginia
where the police have not necessarily
responded
to calls for help so people realize that
to a certain extent
they're on their own and they're
preparing themselves for that
mr christianelli what's also causing
concern is a survey this month which
found that around a third of americans
justify some degree
of violence to advance political goals
a third you proud that four years of
donald trump has led america to this
uh i think your conclusion is uh foolish
um you know the i'll use a simpler
survey that just focused on
college students where they believed
something like a fifth of them and this
was several years ago
that the same conclusion using violence
was okay to stop people
saying what they considered to be
inappropriate speech it was interesting
that overwhelmingly those folks
identified themselves as
liberal so this is a left-wing phenomena
in the united states and and it has
grown
regardless of donald trump this has been
a
more associated with antifa and the kind
of violence that they perpetrate
against people that they don't like you
now have the trump campaign calling for
every able-bodied man and woman to join
the
army for trump's election security
campaign this from donald trump jr
you really want to militarize the
election right like this we've already
seen
the fbi arresting a far-right group from
the so-called wolverine watchmen
who were planning to kidnap the governor
of michigan shouldn't that be
a wake-up call about these militia
groups
and their actions in advance of this
election uh that actually was not a
far-right group
initial reports as usual were wrong but
the fact of the matter is that we don't
want to see any sort of violence
associated with the election
we've had months of civil unrest focused
in
cities where they frankly don't give the
police the authority to
establish peace where that does happen
we in our country we use the national
guard sometimes for that
that peace has been restored and that's
what we want to see and the president
himself has been very emphatic about
that
all over the country regardless of
regardless of politics
you comfortable about these militia
groups forming part of the army for
trump's election security operation
last month militia group one militia
group set up illegal roadblocks
and identity checks in multnomah county
oregon
do you encourage this kind of
lawlessness no you know that's a stupid
question really
um of course not and and again your
connection between different parts
i'm not quite sure why you want to
attack the president so much instead of
assign responsibility for these things
to the people who are responsible for
them
but i i just don't buy into the premise
that underlies your question
isn't perhaps the biggest threat to your
democracy
the failure by the president to commit
to accepting the election result if he
loses
his answer to the question was we'll see
what happens
how does that strengthen people's
confidence in the electoral system in
the us
much like hillary clinton advised joe
biden don't concede no matter what
so they're going to fight it out and
they're going to have an election
and um you hillary clinton's never been
president
and and if you don't if you don't want
me to answer questions i'm not quite
sure why i'm sitting here
um and uh and and that'll play out and
you know you like many others have sort
of bid on that
and the president has never never given
any indication that the outcome of the
election wouldn't be exactly what the
voters determined
it's what it was last time it's what
it's been every time in the history of
the united states and that's what it'll
be this time
and the key for us the key for this
president is that americans
decide that election that we block out
the interference of
of outsiders and that americans votes
are
each counted and each counted once and
properly
and the result will be what it is under
our system and we'll all move on with
that on january 20th regardless of who's
sworn in as the next president
let's talk about the threats you have
highlighted the
acting secretary of your department chad
wolfe recently singled out violent white
supremacist
extremists as being a major concern he
said they'd been exceptionally lethal in
their abhorrent
targeted attacks in recent years
how do you explain the fact that in the
first debate talking about violent
groups the president said
almost everything i see is from the left
wing not from the
right wing is he not seeing what
right-wing violence is
being promised and perpetrated around
are you not showing him those documents
no no i mean but in the last four months
in this country
it's been just cities on fire and that
those are
overwhelmingly left base i'll call them
protests
but really they're riots looting and
violence that's the problem
that's what he was talking about almost
everything i see is from the left wing
not from the right wing
he refused to condemn a group called the
proud boys which were described by the
associated press as a male only group of
neo-fascists who call themselves
western chauvinists in fact he told them
to stand back
and stand by are you happy that the u.s
president tells groups like this to
stand by stand by for what so again you
know you've characterized a group and i
don't
necessarily agree with your
characterization
the pictures i've seen of members of
that are hispanic and black in addition
to white so
you know you got to be a little bit more
careful and discriminating in just
smearing people like that
you know the president wants people to
stay involved and stay engaged he
recently in his capacity as president
not as a candidate
gave federal employees the election day
off to work as election officials to
help
bring off the election safely and
securely
so you know i don't hear you asking
about that
as a candidate he encourages his folks
to participate as volunteers to turn out
votes
to do all the kinds of things you need
to win an election
and and he has two roles here unlike his
opponent
so he's playing them both vigorously and
effectively
so how much of a threat are these
militia groups who may well turn up
armed to the teeth at polling stations
to quote observe
what's going on how worried are you that
people could feel intimidated by that
and that violence could break out
you seem very complacent about it so
we have uh no no no no you're
hypothesizing with no information
there is no intelligence today that a
single polling place of our
approximately very approximately
100 000 across this country
is subject to any such threat if we get
that sort of intelligence
the fbi and its role as a the protector
of civil liberties against civil rights
violations
and threatening people voting would be a
civil rights violation
would take that information and act on
it and they are prepared to do exactly
that
with respect to sort of pop-up violence
things that we don't see coming
state and local law enforcement
officials are as they have
always been responsible for taking care
of that
we will offer them all the help that
they can that we're legally allowed
but the federal government is actually
blocked by
federal law from getting near polling
places
on election day except on very re with
very rare exceptions
miss christianelli your department is
currently under investigation by the
house intelligence committee
after allegations that you and acting
secretary chadwolf
illegally manipulated intelligence to
bolster donald
trump's interests a department spokesman
has denied
these allegations are they all
completely false
yes they are they come from a high level
in fact in fact the yes in fact the same
person
wrote an email um only days before
uh maybe a week before he left his
then position um actually
explicitly stating the opposite so
you know and then the house committee
knows that they have that and
but they have other interests here that
are political so
but so far every single allegation he
made
for which there is information has been
proven
false and you never had meetings with
him in which you told him to modify the
section on white supremacy in your
current threat assessment so as to make
that threat appear
less severe absolutely not
absolutely not and you never expressed
frustration
threat very seriously and you never
expressed frustration
with intelligence reports on central
america
and you had accused unknown deep state
intelligence
analysts of compiling you know only how
slow they went
only how slow they went in your view
does this administration play politics
with the threats
facing the us play them up or play them
down for purely political reasons
absolutely not that's been a media
narrative that's been very popular and
as someone who is at least a role in one
part of it with the department of
homeland security
in a year i have never seen that happen
what about the president's dire warnings
about the caravan of central american
migrants heading towards the border in
2018
he tweeted that criminals and unknown
middle easterners are mixed up with
those people
it wasn't the slightest evidence for
that was that uh no there was
uh you know it's a matter of degree in
terms of how many the most recent
caravan had the same
but our our allies in guatemala first
and then mexico
broke up that caravan and enforced their
own immigration laws in such a way that
those folks were returned home
or turned away from continuing north
well trump himself actually walked the
whole thing back a few hours after he'd
said it and said
there's no proof of anything but there
could very well be that's playing
politics with the
intelligence isn't it the uh well he's a
candidate for president
so you know we do have information about
some of the people who come up in these
caravans it varies time
from one time to another you asked about
2018
there were a lot of caravans in 2018
there haven't been a lot of caravans
this year we've had one
recently that i was referring to and we
do have
information about some of the people who
gather in those
and you know we make use of that we
share it with our allies
along the way and we work together with
them to try to avoid
large-scale illegal immigration and try
to stick to legal
immigration you talked earlier about
the violence in some cities and your
you the president sent federal forces
into portland oregon
during some of these prolonged protests
this summer
you were asked about this violence on a
radio show on october the 1st
and you said one of the worst parts of
it is the encouraging
encouragement it's been getting from so
much of the left-wing
political leadership but in saying that
you seem to have ignored the fact that
they've been some pretty blunt and
frequent condemnations of violence from
senior democrats
why didn't you mention that as well
wow you you ask questions like you're
the communications department for the
democrat national committee here um
i said so many on the left and i'll give
you examples
as i did in that interview i believe the
speaker of the house
attacking law enforcement officers but
not condemning those who are committing
the violence
mayor ted wheeler of portland oregon who
went out to speak to
the violent looters and and they're not
protesters they're rioters
and and he thought they were his friends
and they
shouted him down and began rushing his
space his own police had to declare a
riot and and rush him out of there
governor brown of oregon who in
four months of violence has yet
to use her own national guard she has
over
7 800 national guardsmen whose
part of their purpose is establishing
peace in
when there are violent outbreaks in her
state and she refuses to do it
and instead condemns the administration
for protecting a federal courthouse in
federal buildings in portland oregon
that's so just to be clear you mentioned
adding officers in portland we were
doing that to protect federal facilities
we don't just go into a city
even when they're violent without the
agreement or cooperation of that city
unless we have a federal mission to
perform
so again the first responsibility
typically
in quelling violence and dealing with it
is state or local government
but where there are federal facilities
and where federal
jurisdiction is attacked we have to
respond to that ourselves
many of those who criticize the actions
of your federal
officers cited the use of excessive
force the american civil liberties union
said in august that your
militarized agents used sharp shooters
to maim people
swept protesters away in unmarked cars
and brutally attacked journalists
legal observers and medics with sonic
weapons and tear gas
they didn't spare moms dads veterans
nurses or even the city's mayor
was this law enforcement or punishment
so first of all the characterizations
you recited
are false in portland alone
our officers incurred over 300 injuries
meaning we had
they were injured not causing injuries
and they were very restrained while
dealing with violent protests night
after night
for weeks on end with
often without the help assistance or
support
of local law enforcement because the
local political officials
those same ones i mentioned earlier as
encouraging this sort of behavior
ordered them to hold back so
we used as minimal amount of force as we
could to maintain
safety and to attempt to
quell violence as much as possible you
didn't beat a navy veteran for simply
asking questions
doctors were weren't beaten as they gave
medical support to the injured
yeah no no one that one didn't happen
thankfully
uh but uh with respect to the navy
veteran you're
referring to that was the united states
marshals service
in the department of justice that was
not members of the department of
homeland security
so i i can't really speak to the details
of that
i can say that when a law enforcement
officer is doing their job
they don't have the luxury of inquiring
various
job or life status questions like you
just described
to determine if someone is a veteran or
a mother or a father
or all the various things you named they
don't have that luxury when they're
under attack and trying to protect
themselves
so you're satisfied with all the actions
that your officers carried out then
despite the fact that the aclu said
dhs is too powerful too abusive and too
much of a threat to america's democratic
values
the american civil liberties union has
proven itself an extremely unreliable
um and non-objective characterizer of
events so
you know your reliance on them says more
about where you're coming from than what
the facts were
we're very happy with how our officers
performed
they were professionally restrained over
months
of violence directed at them
and the facilities that they were
protecting including the people in those
facilities
and behave very well no one is ever
perfect we don't expect perfection
but they did an outstanding job and part
of that unfortunately is shown by the
raw number of injuries
they suffered over the course of that
time while inflicting very few
was was the threat exaggerated
president trump said of portland the
entire city
is ablaze all the time that was august
31st
but it wasn't was it the fire service
cities fire and rescue service told him
that in no uncertain terms we're not a
blaze in portland they said
there's a very isolated pocket of
demonstrations that have involved fire
none of which has been substantial
enough to need more than one
fire engines so did the facts get in the
way of
your narrative uh no if you just look at
the federal courthouse when they
uh on numerous occasions attacked the
courthouse
broke front doors you know we're tearing
wood off
and we're throwing liquid accelerant
into the courthouse
and attempting to fire commercial
fireworks in to set it on fire
so they're trying to burn down the
building and kill everyone in it
so you know you you respond accordingly
to that
and even with that kind of a threat we
never used above
non-lethal means to repel those sorts of
attacks so
that seems very appropriate under the
circumstances had the federal officials
not been there
that courthouse would have been burned
to the ground so the city's fire and
rescue service didn't know what they
were talking about
well they've still got a federal
courthouse and they don't have to drive
to another state to have their cases
heard
because federal law enforcement officers
were willing to come in and protect it
there have been fires all over the city
on various days and various places
it isn't just the federal courthouse
it's also police facilities
the police union facility other local
buildings
neighborhoods that they've gone through
so you know
portland's not a big city that's an
awful lot of violence over an awful long
time
it that includes but isn't limited to
the setting of fires
um and uh you know again all over the
city so i think it's accurate to say
there have been fires all over the city
that's true ken cuccinelli thanks for
being on conflict zone
my pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you